[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
genannt und willkommen schön dass sie
dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann für
den sport ein stück von mir und das sind
die wichtigsten themen von heute
krisendiplomatie in europa in kiel
verspricht bundeskanzler scholz dem
ukrainischen präsidenten unterstützung
lockerung der korona regeln bund und
länder erwägen weitgehende öffnungen bis
zum 20 märz
und jubel über bronze beim letzten
skisprung wettkampf der olympischen
spiele wird das deutsche team dritter
kann der bundeskanzler dazu beitragen
einen möglichen einmarsch russlands in
die ukraine zu verhindern dass es die
hoffnung die olaf scholz bei seinen
reisen diese woche begleitet bevor es
morgen nach moskau geht war er heute in
kiel sicherte der ukraine unterstützung
zu auch finanziell aber nach wie vor
keine waffen und er wiederholte
gegenüber moskau sowohl die drohungen
als auch das angebot zum dialog
christiansen
dass olaf scholz zuerst nach kiew
gekommen ist und danach erst nach moskau
fliegt wird in der ukraine wohlwollen
zur kenntnis genommen die botschaft die
von dem treffen ausgehen soll ist klar
deutschland steht fest an der seite der
ukraine wir sind uns einig in der großen
sorge wird die derzeitige lage an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze wir
erwarten deshalb von russland eindeutige
schritte zur deeskalation der
gegenwärtigen spannungen
für die bundesregierung ist klar dass
eine weitere militärische aggression
gegen die ukraine schwerwiegende
politische wirtschaftliche und
geostrategische konsequenzen für
russland zur folge hätte aber die
ukraine erwartet noch mehr von
deutschland als solidarität deutsche
waffen zum beispiel
doch scholz bleibt beim deutschen 1 bei
den angedrohten sanktionen gegen
russland bleibt scholz unkonkret und
auch sie lenski weißt nicht was
deutschland will ich habe keine antwort
auf die frage bekommen welche sanktionen
gegen die russische föderation zwecks
deeskalation abgestimmt worden sind ich
habe diese frage dem kanzler und den
anderen staats und regierungschefs in
den vergangenen wochen mehrfach gestellt
statt waffen verspricht deutschland
frisches geld durch die beschleunigte
auszahlung weiterer 150 millionen euro
aus einem laufenden kredit im
mittelpunkt aber stand einer der heute
gar nicht da war wladimir putin der
beriet sich mit außenminister lavrov in
moskau eine inszenierte fragestunde am
langen tisch
ist ihrer meinung nach noch eine chance
mit unseren partnern eine einigung über
wichtige themen zu erzielen die uns
sorgen bereiten oder ist es nur ein
versuch und sind endlose verhandlungen
zu ziehen
ohne logische schlussfolgerung
und lavrov antwortet seinem präsidenten
als chef des auswärtigen amtes muss ich
sagen dass es immer eine chance gibt
moskau spricht von chancen und derwesten
sucht wege zur deeskalation
fortsetzung morgen in moskau
fragende theo koll in berlin welche
botschaft ging heute von dieser
schiffsreise auf
botschaften haben in dieser krise immer
mindestens zwei empfänger kiew und
moskau die botschaft in und an kiew war
wir sind weiter solidarisch keiner gibt
mehr geld als deutschland wir zahlen
auch noch mal 150 millionen aber waffen
gibt es nicht außer vielleicht
nachtsicht oder minen räumgeräte und
eine mitgliedschaft der ukraine bleibe
weiter möglich stehe aber nicht auf der
tagesordnung das war dann auch schon ein
teil der botschaft und einen schritt
richtung moskau keine sorge eine nato
erweiterung ist derzeit kein thema
gleichzeitig hat olaf scholz aber zum
ersten mal auch sehr deutlich gesagt
dass es bei den sanktionen um die
wirtschaft geht zitat kanzler es geht um
sehr weitreichende maßnahmen die
erheblichen einfluss auf die ökonomische
entwicklungsmöglichkeit russland hätten
und damit scheint auch klar es geht nur
um die wirtschaft danke für einen nach
berlin theo koll war dass
auch die bundeswehr versucht dem
russischen truppen aufmarsch an der
ukrainischen grenze etwas entgegen zu
setzen und verstärkt jetzt ihre kräfte
in litauen erste soldaten wurden heute
von niedersachsen aus verlegt 350 sollen
es in den nächsten tagen werden dazu
kommt militärisches material unter an
sechs panzerhaubitzen mit jeweils einer
reichweite von mindestens 30 kilometern
seit jahren führt deutschland in litauen
den einsatz einer nato einheit mit etwa
1200 soldaten natalie steger berichtet
touchdown mit verstärkung am flughafen
von kaunas kommen die ersten 70
zusätzlichen soldatinnen und soldaten
der bundeswehr an im rahmen des nato
einsatzes in litauen die bündnispartner
drängen auf mehr deutsches engagement
ein deutliches zeichen dafür dass wir in
der lage sind innerhalb kürzester zeit
werden die notwendigkeit besteht kräfte
hier nach litauen zu verlegen die truppe
wird schlagkräftiger in munster in
niedersachsen macht sich derweil ein
transport mit schwerem militärischem
gerät in richtung litauen auf fahrzeuge
und panzerhaubitzen
deutschland führt in dem baltischen land
den nato einsatz wir sind nun hier und
wir sind bereit und entschlossen unseren
auftrag zu erfüllen ihr auftrag
abschreckung russlands seit 2017
trainieren den litauen etwa 600 deutsche
soldaten plus truppen aus anderen nato
nationen den ernstfall die westlichen
truppen sollen sicherheit vermitteln
russland für die balken der ewige feind
die gefühlte bedrohung durch moskau ist
in der ex sowjetrepublik wieder spürbar
ich hoffe dass ich die nato als wirklich
starker verbündeter zeigt und wird auch
nicht alleine lässt wenn es zu einem
krieg m
sind nato-mitglied sie wird uns in jeder
situation hält
nun also verstärkt deutschland den
einsatz
die zusätzlichen deutschen soldaten sind
für litauen ein schritt in die richtige
richtung insgesamt aber ist für liter
und berlins haltung in der ukraine krise
zu zögerlich dass deutschland auch
weiterhin keine waffen an die ukraine
liefern will wird im baltikum kritisch
gesehen
kriegsgefahr in europa dazu gibt es ein
zdf spezial direkt nach uns
zur coroner lage vor dem bund länder
treffen übermorgen zeichnet sich ab es
wird bald lockerungen geben gestützt
auch auf die aktuellen zahlen die zeigen
der scheitelpunkt der omicron welle
könnte erreicht sein seit tagen geht die
zahl der neuinfektionen zurück heute
meldet das ak ii 76
1465 positive tests und nach dem anstieg
seit jahresende sinkt die sieben tage
incidents zum zweiten mal in folge sie
liegt aktuell bei 1400
59,8 das erhöht die chance
auflockerungen klaus brodbeck
das könnte bald vorbei sein
beschränkungen kontrollen verwirrung was
denn wo gilt zwei tage vor dem nächsten
bund länder treffen werden die rufe nach
lockerungen immer lauter wir müssen den
menschen in unserem land zeigen dass ein
ende der freiheitseinschränkende
maßnahmen unmittelbar bevorsteht eine
beschlussvorlage aus dem kanzleramt
stand kurz vor mitternacht macht
hoffnung dass nach dem treffen die
zugangskontrollen im einzelhandel
entfallen private treffen sollen mit bis
zu 20 personen möglich seien ungeimpfte
ausgenommen ab vierten märz soll gelten
3g für gastronomie und
übernachtungsgewerbe zweig plus für
diskotheken und clubs und
großveranstaltungen zudem dürften mehr
rein 40 prozent auslastung maximal 4000
personen in innenräumen 60 prozent bis
maximal
25.000 im freien hat zwanzigster märz
sollen alle tiefgreifenden schutz
maßnahmen wegfallen das gilt dann auch
für die pflicht home office anzubieten
es ist auf jeden fall schon mal eine
gute diskussionsgrundlage für die
konferenz am mittwoch wir haben ja immer
von unserer seite aus gesagt dass wir um
ikon aufmerksam beobachtet haben auch
beobachtet haben wie sich die situation
in unserem land verändert wir müssen
natürlich vorsichtig vorgehen in dieser
in diesen zusammenhängen vor allem auch
in schulen darauf achten dass die maske
pflicht das auch das testen weiterhin
aufrecht erhalten bleibt damit der
schulunterricht gewährleistet werden
kann und er soll weiter geimpft werden
an der allgemeinen impfpflicht die
beschlussvorlage jedenfalls fest
alles am laufen halten trotz vieler
krankmeldungen das war und ist eine
herausforderung dieser mikrowelle zieht
man eine erste bilanz dann ist es
bislang weitgehend gelungen
krankenpflege stromversorgung müllabfuhr
alles funktioniert noch auch dank
geschickter organisation aus münchen
berichtet simon von fett
60.000 tonnen pro tag das ist das pensum
der münchner abfallwirtschaft dass es
dafür immer genug personal gibt es eine
herausforderung in der pandemie
berichtet uns die werksleiterin aktuell
selbst in corona isolation corona macht
sich deutlich bemerkbar allerdings zum
glück nicht in der intensität und länge
wie wir es befürchtet hätten aktuell
haben wir immer plus minus 50
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die
wegen einer positiven corona erkrankung
ausfallen der müll wird dennoch abgeholt
energie und wasserversorgung
funktionieren wohl auch mal im besonders
sensiblen bereichen häufig darauf
geachtet wurde dass in festen teams und
getrennten schichten gearbeitet wird im
öffentlichen verkehr hat es nur
vereinzelt ausfälle gegeben waren die
warnungen vor der omicron welle also
übertrieben oder haben masken pflicht
und 3g schlicht gewirkt ich würde es
eher als lob interpretieren dass sich
alle so gut dran gehalten haben dass es
kein zug ein kollaps gekommen ist denn
er war seriell die omikron welle bewegt
sich auf ihren höhepunkt zu jetzt
schnell die korona maßnahmen zu lockern
das könnte zu früh gekommen waren
vertreter der kritischen infrastrukturen
gott sei dank sind die auswirkungen im
moment von omikron jetzt nicht so stark
aber
sieben tage krank ist sieben tage krank
und was ist wenn der schlüssel
mitarbeiter krank ist ein vertreter
krank ist wie soll dann die versorgung
sichergestellt
deshalb sei weiterhin vorsicht geboten
damit auch die bereiche weiter laufen in
denen home office keine option ist
seit wochen behindern gegner von corona
maßnahmen in kanada massiv den verkehr
parkende trucks liegen teile der
hauptstadt ottawa lahm mittlerweile
erreicht diese form des protests auch
europa ein sogenannter freiheits konvoi
wollte heute durch brüssel rollen die
behörden kontrollierten etwa 500
fahrzeuge einige würden auf einen
parkplatz am stadtrand umgeleitet wegen
der kontrollen war die autobahn von
aachen nach brüssel zeitweise gesperrt
der unter terrorverdacht stehende
ehemalige bundeswehroffizier franco ist
wieder in untersuchungshaft wegen flucht
und verdunklungsgefahr
bei einer kontrolle wurden bei ihm
gegenstände gefunden die als
beweismittel dienen könnten 2017 hatte
sich frank ua eine schein identität als
syrischer flüchtlinge zugelegt er soll
terroranschläge geplant haben für die
dann migranten verantwortlich gemacht
werden sollten die staatsanwaltschaft
wirft ihm völkisch nationalistische
motive vor
fast 2000 schiffbauer in mecklenburg
vorpommern erwarteten heute
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck in der
hoffnung auf hilfe
wenige wochen nach den insolvenzanträgen
der mv werften und des asiatischen
mutterkonzerns steht die zukunft der
mitarbeitenden in den sternen das gilt
auch für die global dream ein
unvollendetes kreuzfahrtschiffe
9500 passagiere aus wismar statt fett
mut will er machen
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
im gespräch mit mitarbeitern der mv
werften in wismar ein wichtiger schritt
die fertigstellung der global green and
dog sie leistet einen beitrag
möglicherweise durch die arbeit hier zum
erhalt des werften standortes und damit
dann zur zukünftigen aus der zukünftigen
aufstellung transformation
offshore-plattform bln die schiffe zu
produzieren und auf höchstem standard zu
entwickeln die dann auch die schifffahrt
perspektivisch emissionsärmer und dann
irgendwann emissionsfrei machen der
rettende weiterbau des kreuzfahrt
giganten würde etwa 600 millionen euro
kosten dafür gibt es bisher keinen
käufer interessenten aber schon
zwischenzeitlich sind es
glücklicherweise noch ein paar dazu
gekommen die auch ernsthaft sind so dass
wir hier inzwischen recht guter dinge
sind dass es gelingen wird einen käufer
zu finden
aber die zeit drängt ab märz sind die
etwa 2000 mitarbeiter auf
überbrückungshilfen angewiesen der
betriebsrat hofft auf
transfergesellschaften und einen
transfer kurzarbeitergeld der
öffentlichen hand deswegen fordern wir
das gemeinsame mittel vom bund und land
bereitgestellt werden damit die kollegen
im team vor ort bleiben sich
qualifizieren für zukünftige projekte
und nicht in alle winde verstreut werden
fachkräfte halten um eine chance zu
haben unter neuen investoren weiter zu
machen erst mal das große ziel an
werftstandorten wismar
in bayern ist beim zusammenstoß zweier
s-bahnen mindestens ein mensch ums leben
gekommen etwa 30 weitere wurden verletzt
das unglück ereignete sich gegen 16 uhr
40 südlich von münchen in der gemeinde
schäftlarn im bahnhofsbereich des
ortsteils ebenhausen schäftlarn
kollidierten die züge über die
unglücksursache ist noch nichts bekannt
auf öffentlichen plätzen wurde heute
vielerorts getanzt mit ernstem
hintergrund die aktion heißt one belgien
rising eine milliarde erhebt sich sie
will wie hier in berlin auf gewalt an
frauen und mädchen aufmerksam machen
etwa jede dritte wird nach einer uno
statistik im laufe ihres lebens
misshandelt oder vergewaltigt also eine
milliarde frau jedes jahr am 14 februar
ruft die bewegung dazu auf tanzend zu
protestieren
zeichen setzen haltung zeigen nicht
tanzend aber mit einer wohl platzierten
politischen geste das gelang dem rapper
eminem vor dem millionenpublikum des
super bowl in los angeles
dieses saisonfinale im american football
ist längst mehr als ein sportereignis
gewonnen haben übrigens die ems benjamin
daniel hat details
dieses elfi wollten sich die beiden
nicht entgehen lassen amerikas mega
sportevents lässt zumindest für ein paar
stunden eine gespaltene nation ein stück
zusammenrücken
wenige minuten zuvor nach einem kopf an
kopf spiel die szene des abends
85 sekunden vor schluss touchdown los
angeles sid der rems im heimischen
stadion metz deckert liefert den
entscheidenden pass auf kuba cup
entstand 23 zu 20 dieses spektakel ist
matthias aus hamburg 5000 euro wert
gewesen
wohin mit all ihren möglichen und
wenn ich immer zu hause in die
rheinstadt mal bezahlt jeder muss nur
wollen in der halbzeitshow sorgte dieser
kniefall eminems für wirbel zeichen des
protests gegen rassismus und
polizeigewalt gegen schwarze viele
konservative im land empfinden die gäste
die erstmals 2016 von football profi
colin cappek gemacht wurde als
respektlos das dürfte also auch den
mächtigen in der nfl hauptsächlich weiße
männer nicht gefallen habe und so wurde
der viel beschriebene spalt in der
amerikanischen gesellschaft an diesem
abend doch noch sichtbar
und jetzt der blick nach peking norbert
zu erfolgreichen deutschen skispringer
ein dramatischer teamwettbewerb bei
minus 24 grad in chaco die dsv-athleten
sicherten sich hauchdünn die
bronzemedaille von norwegen österreich
gewinnt gold silber ging nach slowenien
der sprung aus olympische siegerpodest
nach einer ganz engen entscheidung
markus eisenbichler hatte die deutschen
im zweiten durchgang mit der
tagesbestweite von 139 eineinhalb metern
dicht an die auf bronze liegenden
norweger gebracht
aber das ist es wert hat irgendwas werts
medaille und legal wursthorn das fünfte
gold 0,8 punkte umgerechnet 44 cm
machten am ende den unterschied
schlussspringer karl geiger kam mit den
schwierigen windbedingungen besser klar
als der norwegische olympiasieger mario
sind weg mit bronze im team wettbewerb
gab es ein happy end für die deutschen
skispringer in changsha co
der internationale sportgerichtshof cas
hat im dopingfall der russischen
eiskunstläuferin kamera live ein urteil
gefällt die 15 jährige darf morgen im
einzelwettbewerb um eine weitere
medaille kämpfen in moskau wird die
entscheidung der sportjuristen begrüßt
camila wir sind mit dir steht hier
großflächig an einer hauswand damit
scheiterte unter anderem des ioc mit dem
versuch camila ballier war das
startrecht für morgen zu entziehen als
minderjährige gilt sie als geschützte
person innerhalb des anti doping codes
die vorläufige suspendierung hätte ihr
unter umständen einen irreparablen
schaden zugefügt daher hat man zwischen
fairness und den interessen abgewogen
für eine athletin die bei diesen spielen
nicht positiv getestet worden ist
sollte weil hier war morgen eine weitere
medaille gewinnen wird es wieder blumen
zeremonie noch siegerehrung geben
beschloss das ioc camila weil jeder
läuft damit unter vorbehalt
bob dominator francesco friedrich hat
zur halbzeit des zvei renz sein drittes
olympia gold im visier zusammen mit
anschieber torsten marx stellt der
gleich im ersten lauf einen neuen start
und bahnrekord auf der zweite lauf dann
etwas schwächer so konnte sein
zweitplatzierter teamkollege johannes
lochner aufschließen die entscheidung
dann morgen ja noch ein kurzer blick auf
die fußball bundesliga und die beiden
sonntagsspiele dortmund gewinnt bei
union berlin mit 3 zu 0 danach
hoffenheims sieg über bielefeld benjamin
hübner trifft in der 22 kurz nach der
pause machte john jr alles klar für die
tsg hoffenheim jetzt tabellenfünfter
arminia bleibt fünfzehnter
einer begegnung alle todesspiel tags zu
sehen bei uns auf zdf heute.de und in
der heute ein geschenk schnell jetzt
nach der wochen in sonne wird es jetzt
deutlich wechselhafter und ab
wochenmitte stürmisch die details zur
beta hat vielleicht katja viertel vor
zehn begrüßt sie christian sievers im
heute-journal danke für ihr interesse
machen sie sich noch einen schönen abend
und bis abend wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
guten abend nach dem sonnen hoch ingo
vom wochenende übernehmen jetzt die
thies die bringen regen ein bisschen
schnee vor allen dingen aber sehr viel
wind mit heute nacht regnet es im
nordwesten und auch hier im süden fällt
regen zum teil ist es auch schnee
oberhalb von 800 bis 1000 meter so kann
es glatt werden denn dem süden bayerns
sinken die temperaturen auf plus 2 bis
minus 1 grad sonst bleibt die nacht
etwas milder die höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen den westlichen und dem
südlichen bayern bei 4 bis 6 grad sonst
werden so 7 bis 10 grad erreicht und
auch morgen fällt noch regen oder schnee
hier im süden zum teil ist aber auch
ganz freundlich nord östlich der weser
aber im nordwesten kommen dann schon die
dichteren wolken an die bringen regen
mit und der wind nimmt schon durch zu
das ist ein süd südwest wind und dann
kommt der mittwoch und der war total
verregnet sein bei temperaturen von
sechs bis 13 grad der donnerstag bringt
dann sturm an der küste aber nicht nur
dort sondern auch in den mittelgebirgen
und am freitag droht vielleicht sogar
ein orkan dann steigen die temperaturen
vorher aber noch mal bis 17 grad guten
abend